this is with us Jen's is in Florida hi
ends how are you good how are you doing
sir better than I deserve what's up had
a sister-in-law that is serving in the
military and she's actually maybe
stationed down enira and my wife and I
were considering offering our place for
her just that she's in quite a bit of
debt and we wanted to try to help her
get out of debt and she gets quite a bit
for her housing allowance so we were
thinking of maybe offering our plates
for four or five hundred dollars a month
and just wanted to hear your opinion on
that your place you don't live in it no
no just a room out of our home I'll let
her let her room in your place in your
house I see that yes sir okay um hold is
she 40 okay and is she working to get
out of that no not currently we have got
her the FPU class right um but she has
had she's been somewhat reluctant to go
so we're hoping we can be encouraging it
when she moves here yeah okay and how
long do you think she'll be stationed in
your area hmm about three years I don't
know if would be the game plan that you
have her stay with us for three years
with relatives renting from them doing
business with them or working with them
is there unclear about the exact
parameters of the deal okay and that's
where people end up getting mad and so I
would put exact clear parameters on the
deal from a relationship standpoint I
would write out a one-page agreement not
as a legal agreement but just this is
what we are agreeing to you can stay
here up to two years at zero rent as
long as you are putting over X number of
dollars onto your debt as a
salt of that and that needs to be way
more than 500 it ought to be like big
like 2000 or whatever number big number
and you're looking at her budget and
you're saying in other words you're
working a plan to get out of debt and so
we're gonna let you live here for free
as our gift to encourage you and be your
cheerleader on that up to two years
that's what I would do and do that as a
gift to my sister-in-law okay would you
suggest having any charging her for
bread no no that's what I'm saying I
would encourage her you can if you want
but I would just give it to her as a
gift it doesn't cost that much to have
her there
maybe she chips in something for food
but her being there she's never there
she's at work and her being there's not
gonna really add to your expenses
substantially I mean again you got to
work out something on the food issue but
she's probably eating on base most of
the time or on the job or whatever she's
doing out there and so you know you work
out some kind of a detail on food but I
really I would just do that to encourage
her unless you just desperately need
money do you need money
no no okay okay I mean but I would not
let her live there and pursue nothing
yeah under any circumstance it up yeah
you get an up-close-and-personal
you get a front front-row seat to her
stupidity they'll just make you mad yeah
you don't wanna do that and so you can
be wants to work this plan will help you
and participate with you and you're
gonna show us that you're doing that and
that's the only thing your rent cost you
is you have to open up your life a
little bit and show us and we're gonna
be your accountability partners and your
cheerleader but if you want to continue
down the path of stupidity lives
somewhere else and we will love you from
a little bit more of a distance we still
love you as much we Ilana everybody's
got stupid people in their family I mean
you just have to love them at more of a
distance than your spare bedroom you
know that's all you want to do and it's
not just money stupid there's all kinds
of stupid things people do you know so
you just got to think that through but
lots of Claire
ride it out and it's all about
encouragement it's not about you being a
micromanager or something and by the way
you don't have to live here it's okay
we're still gonna be friends we're still
gonna love you you may not want to live
here you may not want to do this and
that's okay
but if you're gonna live here we're
gonna let you do it for free and in
return you're gonna pass 2,300 ollars a
month and that or whatever the number in
the budget tells you it should be
because she's got zero rent and she
ought to be racking it up man she had to
be you know hitting the nail on hitting
the hammer on the nail every dadgum
month and just kicking this thing kick
it kick it kick it make it happen